We've seen
an exclusive now
about the actions and apparent
inconsistent statements
made by one of the top law
enforcement officers
who responded to the Rob
Elementary School
shooting in Texas back in May.
21 people were murdered that day,
including 19 children.
Ruben Nolasco
Nolasco is the sheriff of Uvalde,
the county.
His actions that day have so far
avoided the same level of scrutiny
of other top
officers, one of whom was fired,
another who retired
before he could be fired.
As you're
about to learn,
however, Sheriff
Nolasco had vital information
about the shooter
and since that awful day, the statements
he's given appear to contradict
body camera
evidence, as well as his own comments
to CNN Shimon Prokupecz.
Now, this includes statements
about when he arrived on scene
and crucially,
whether he heard about a 911
call from a girl trapped
inside the school
with the shooter,
knowledge that should have prompted
an immediate direct response,
according to active shooter training.
Shimon has the details for us tonight.
We want to warn you,
some of what you see
you're about to see is disturbing
and difficult to watch.
Do you think that your
response that day was adequate?
Your response
and the way you handled the scene,
do you think that was that quick guide?
You think that your response
that day was adequate
improving?
Six months
after the police response
deemed an abject failure
by the top cop in Texas.
That Uvalde County sheriff
is defending his actions
at Rob Elementary.
No, you don't know everything.
There's a lot. Don't we know, sir?
Tell us what we don't know.
What are you going to say?
That you didn't know
that there was a 911 call with you?
Didn't talk all you want?
I've already told you I can't.
What are you going to tell us?
That you didn't know
that there were kids
inside the classroom.
Tell us right now
that you didn't know that there were kids
inside that classroom,
that there's no response.
Did Sheriff
Rubin Alaska
was the highest ranking law enforcement
official in Uvalde County.
I can't break.
I can break. Careful.
He was an integral part
of this police failure.
From its earliest moments.
But the elected official
has so far avoided scrutiny.
Nolasco claims
he was headed to the school
when he diverted to a home nearby
After being told
a woman was shot in the face,
he can be heard over the radio.
Shock. Find someone on one side.
You go, go, go.
Ahead, lane on
the screen,
the lone female shot in the head.
He is the first person to learn two key
pieces of information
the shooter's name
and that he had already attempted
to kill his grandmother.
Okay, well, who did this to you?
Who is your grandson?
Justin.
Christopher
It's information
that would have been immediately
useful to police at the school
where there was confusion over
who the gunman was
and what his intentions were.
As an ambulance arrived at
the grandmother's house.
Sheriff Nolasco
tried to figure out what was going on.
One of his deputies clued him in Okay,
so what's what's going on? I got you.
I got your camera. Okay.
So what am I missing on the right
there, Sheriff?
Right here at the funeral.
Okay. Did you have him surrounded?
When I last spoke to Texas Rangers
investigating the response in June,
he said he couldn't recall
what time he left the grandmother's house
and arrived at Rob
speaking to CNN six months later.
Nolasco has a different story.
You know what truly happened?
You were there
35 minutes after it.
It started.
Okay,
so I wasn't there
for the first 35 minutes,
at least the first 35 minutes.
But 35 minutes is not accurate.
He was there sooner was a guy
and a fast food sheriff.
I don't know what's happening.
Okay.
Listen to CNN analysis of body
camera footage
shows
Nolasco arrived that Rob at 11:49 a.m.
just 16 minutes after the shooter
first went inside not 35 16
Okay once on scene
the 30 year
law enforcement
veteran can be seen giving orders.
What we can do is move everybody he's
just outside the school
when a dispatch came over
the police radio.
That should have changed everything.
A ten year old girl called 911 and said
she was in the room with the shooter
surrounded by bodies
Speaking to investigators and to CNN,
Nolasco claimed
the radios inside the school
didn't work,
and so he didn't know
there were any children
trapped in the room.
You were never told that there were
that there were 911 calls.
You never heard the radio.
The radio were not working in that area.
They were working.
So Okay.
You're wrong about that.
The transmission can be heard over
several police radios
within earshot of Nolasco.
It
and then a Uvalde a police
officer tells him to tell
people
which way.
According to training,
Nolasco should have immediately organized
the officers
to storm the room
to try and save the children.
We're going to get
your kids out that way.
So you gentlemen want to help us.
Instead,
he leads a group in the wrong direction
to help clear children
from other classrooms
who weren't under immediate threat.
In recorded interviews obtained by CNN.
Joe Betancourt, a
captain with the Texas Department
of Public Safety,
who is under internal investigation
for his own response
to the shooting,
told investigators
Sheriff Nolasco was, quote,
running
the show, had spoken to the sheriff
on the way up here in Alaska.
He had
said that it was a
student, the male
that was in there
and in the school with an AK 47.
He was barricaded.
And the sheriff has,
you know, operation in control there
at the time.
And, you know,
we're getting with the sheriff
to get information,
firsthand information,
you know, from from the incident
as it was occurring,
that you told him
it was a barricaded situation
and that it was
someone armed with an AK 47.
I never said that.
You never said that. No.
He said that it was his impression,
based on his conversations with you,
that you were the commander on scene.
Again, it's his impression
and that's that's on him.
Okay. He's a he's a captain.
And that's what he assumed.
Then it was an assumption.
It was not validated.
Why wouldn't
you have ordered your officers inside
that room,
your deputies?
Why wouldn't
you take a leadership role and say,
we need to get inside
that classification?
That got to me when I got there was
it was a barricaded individual.
That's it.
So when you have a very barricaded
individual,
it changes the dynamics of everything.
So that's what was relate to me.
Yeah.
The belief that the gunman was barricaded
instead of an active shooter
had catastrophic consequences
in the moments
after the room was finally breached
and the horrors inside are revealed.
No, nothing going on here in Nolasco
speaks with a Texas Ranger
who has been suspended
pending an investigation
into his own actions.
He still seems confused about
what they should have done differently
or
the day after the shooting.
Alaska Republican and political
ally of Texas Governor
Greg Abbott will play a key
role in briefing lawmakers
where incorrect information was provided.
And in a
combative interview with Texas Rangers
nine days after the shooting,
Nolasco was emotional and belligerent,
complaining about leaks, police
being called cowards
and facing media scrutiny.
It's been very traumatic for me as well.
And I understand
you know, not being able to quit
being called the pussy
and cowards.
That's it, guys.
But what about the fact
and when a Texas House committee
investigating the response
asked the sheriff
to appear for testimony.
Nolasco initially refused
until the committee
was forced to send him formal notice.
Six months later,
it's clear he's
still unwilling to face
difficult questions.
Y'all don't care about the families.
You are here for your ratings.
That's all that's Y'all are here for.
Okay, so that that's real.
Is that what you think? No.
You know,
that's what you're here for, too.
For the ratings,
what have you done for the family.
I'll Human Progress joins us now.
I mean, for him to say
that is is beneath contempt
It's unfortunate.
Let's just talk, though,
about what he did and didn't do.
I mean, this guy's
a is a public elected official.
Is there any accountability
that he faces?
Not really clear on this.
And the thing that's going on,
the county commission,
which kind of oversees him
and maybe oversees the county.
They have ordered
an internal investigation,
but it's not clear
what that is going to result in
whether or not
he can get removed from office,
they can hold him accountable
for any of this.
Because when you look
at some of the other law
enforcement leaders,
they've either been removed,
they've resigned,
there's been accountability.
But with him,
because he's an elected official
and because he's the sheriff,
it's not very clear
to really anyone that I've talked to that
there can be any accountability.
We should also be clear,
just we've had a number of family members
on this program over the last month
as we continue
to cover this and determine to do it.
And you're doing extraordinary
work on that.
You talk to family members often.
How did they feel about
the sheriff's action?
they have been raising a lot of concerns
and a lot of questions
about the sheriff's actions that day
and the fact
that he has not been open
about what he did.
He had 13 deputies.
13 of his deputies were on scene there.
Several of them were in the hallway.
One of them actually was in a team
that breached that classroom
and killed the gunman.
So they have felt that the sheriff
has not been forthcoming.
They feel that he has some culpability.
They feel that he has some
answers that they need
for what happened here.
The other thing what's interesting
is that with the sheriff,
when the House committee back in July,
when they were doing their that Texas
House committee
was doing an investigation,
they had called the sheriff to come in
and give a deposition.
He had initially refused,
claiming that, you know,
there was this investigation.
He couldn't cooperate.
He ultimately cooperated.
But people certainly in this community,
you know, the mayor
who I've talked to several times,
all feel
that the sheriff
is hiding something,
that he's not been forthcoming
about information.
So that is the way
certainly the community
and certainly families
feel about the sheriff in front of us.
Appreciate it. Thanks for reporting.